the data for your supervised learning
problem comprises input X and output
labels Y what have you going through
your data you find that some of these
upper labels Y are incorrect the up data
which is incorrectly labeled is it worth
your while to go in to fix up some of
these labels let's take a look in the
classification problem y equals 1 for
cats and 0 for non cats so let's say
you're looking through some data and
that's a cat that smelly cat does the
cat there's a cat that's not a cat
that's a cat
you know wait that's actually not a cat
so this is an example with an incorrect
label so I've used the term mislabeled
examples to refer to if your learning
algorithm I'll put the wrong value of Y
but I'm going to say incorrectly labeled
examples when to refer to if in the data
set you have in a training set or the
death set or the test set the label for
Y whenever a human label assigned to
this piece of data is actually incorrect
and that's actually a dog so that Y
really should have been 0 but maybe the
laborer got that one wrong so if you
find that your data has some incorrectly
labeled examples what should you do well
first let's consider the training set it
turns out that deep learning algorithms
are quite robust to random errors in the
training set so so long as your errors
or your incorrectly labeled examples so
once those errors are not too far from
random you know maybe sometimes on the
labourer just wasn't paying attention or
they accidentally randomly hit the wrong
key on keyboard if the errors are
reasonably random then it's probably ok
to just leave the errors as they are and
not spend too much time fixing them
there's certainly no harm to going into
your training set and be examining the
labels and fixing them sometimes that is
worth doing but your alpha might be okay
even if you don't so long as the total
data set size is big enough
and actual percentage of errors is you
know maybe not too high so I see a lot
of machine learning algorithms that are
trained even when we know that there are
a few it's mistakes in the training side
labels and usually works ok there is one
caveat to this which is that people only
albums are robust random errors they are
less robust to systematic errors so for
example if your labels consistently
labeled white dogs as we had then that
is a problem because your classifier
will learn to classify on white colored
dogs as cats for random errors or near
random errors are usually not too bad
for most deep learning algorithms now
this discussion has focus on what to do
about incorrectly labeled examples in
your training set how about incorrectly
labeled examples in your def set or test
set if you're worried about the impact
of incorrectly labeled examples on your
deaf set or test set what I recommend
you do is drink error analysis to add
one extra column so that you can also
count up the number of examples where
the label Y was in your eggs so for
example maybe when you count up the
impact on a hundreds label deficit
examples so you're going to find 100
examples where your concise output
disagrees with the label in your def set
and sometimes for a few of those
examples your classifier disagrees with
the label because the label was wrong
rather than because you caused by wrong
so maybe in this example you find that
the label amidst a cat in the background
so um put a check mark there to signify
that example 98 had an incorrect label
and maybe for this one the picture is
actually a picture of a drawing of a cat
garden in a row cat and maybe you want
the neighborhoods of label that y equals
zero while rather than y equals one and
so you put another check mark there and
just as you count up the percent of
errors due to other categories like we
saw in a previous video you'd also count
up
percentage of errors due to incorrect
labels whether Y value in the DEF set
was wrong and that accounted for while
your learning algorithm made the
prediction that differed from what the
label on your data says so the question
now is is it worthwhile going in to try
to fix up you know this six percent of
the incorrectly labeled examples my
advice is if it makes a significant
difference to your ability to evaluate
algorithms on your def set then go ahead
and spend the time to fix the incorrect
labels but if it doesn't make a
significant difference to your ability
to use the DEF set to value classifiers
then it might not be the best use of
your time let me show you an example
that illustrates what I mean by this
so three numbers I recommend you look at
to try to decide if it's worth going in
and reducing the number of miss labor
examples are the following recommend you
look at the overall def set error and so
in the example we had from the previous
video we said that maybe a system has
90% overall accuracy so 10 percent error
then you should look at the number of
errors or the percentage of errors
they're due to incorrect labels so it
looks like in this case 6 percent of the
errors are due to incorrect labels so
six percent of 10 percent is 0.6 percent
and then you should look at errors due
to all other causes so if you made 10
percent error on your def set and a
point 6 percent of those are because the
labels are wrong then the remainder 9
point 4 percent of them are due to other
causes such as miss recognizing dark
spring attacks great calves and very
images so in this case I would say
there's nine point four percent worth of
error that you could focus on fixing
whereas you know the errors due to
incorrect labels is a relatively small
fraction of the overall set of errors so
by all means go in and fix these
incorrect labels if you want but this
may be not the most important thing to
do right now now let's take another
example suppose you've made a lot more
progress on your learning problem so
instead of 10
era let's say you brought the arrows
down to two percent but still zero point
six percent of your overall errors are
due to incorrect labels so now if you
were to examine a set of mislabel def
set images so set that comes from this
two percent of deficit data you're
misleading then a lot a very large
fraction of them 0.6 divided by two
percent so there's actually 30 percent
rather than 6 percent of your labels of
your incorrect examples are actually due
to incorrectly labeled examples and so
errors due to other causes are now 1.4
percent when such a higher fraction of
your mistakes at least as measured on
your def set are due to incorrect labels
then it maybe seems much more worthwhile
to fix up the incorrect labels in your
depth set and if you remember the goal
of the death set the main purpose of the
death set is you want to really use it
to help you select between two
qualifiers a and B so they're trying out
two confines a and B and one has 2.1
percent error and the other has 1.9
percent error on your death sentence but
if you don't trust your deathbed anymore
to be correctly telling you whether this
classifier is actually better than this
because you're open 6 percent of these
mistakes I'll do two incorrect labels
then that's a good reason to go in and
fix the incorrect labels in your death
set because in this example on the right
is just having a very large impact on
the overall assessments of the errors of
the algorithm roasting example the nut
you know the percentage impact is having
on your algorithm is still smaller now
if you decide to go into your dev set
and manually re-examine the labels and
try to fix up some of the labels here
are a few additional guidelines or
principles to consider first I would
encourage you to apply whatever process
you apply to both your depth and test
set at the same time we talked
previously about why you want your depth
intense
as the conferencing distribution the DEF
set is sort of telling you where to aim
target and when you hit it you want that
to generalize to the test set so your
team really works more efficiently the
debit test sets come from the same
distribution so if you're going in to
fix up your dev sets I would apply the
same process the test set to make sure
that they continue to come from the same
distribution so if you hire someone to
examine your labels will carefully do
that for both your dev and test sets
second I would urge you to consider
examining examples your algorithm got
right as was once it got wrong it is
easy to look at the examples your album
got wrong and just see if any of those
need to be fixed but it's possible that
there are some examples that you haven't
got right that should also be fixed and
the only fixed ones that your albums got
wrongly end up with a more bias estimate
of the error of your algorithm it kind
of gives you albumin a little bit of an
unfair advantage if you just try to
double-check what it got wrong but you
don't also double-check what it got
right because it might have gotten
something right that it was you know
just lucky on and fixing the label would
cause it to go from being right to be
wrong on that example the second bullet
isn't always easy to do so it's not
always done the reason it's not always
done is because if you classify as very
accurate then it's getting a lot fewer
things wrong then right so if your
classifier has your 98% accuracy then
it's getting two percent of things wrong
and 98 percent of things right so it's
much easier to examine and very
validating labels on 250 good data and
it takes much longer to validate the
labels on 98 percent data so this isn't
always done but it's just something to
consider finally if you go into your DEP
and test data to correct on the label
there
you may or may not decide to go and
apply the same process for the training
set remember we said that the size this
video there's actually less important to
correct on tables in your training set
and it's quite possible you decide to
just correct the labels in your Devon
test set which are also often smaller
than the training set and you might not
invest all that extra effort needed to
correct the labels in a much larger
training set this is actually okay and
we'll talk later this week about some
processes for handling when your
training data is different and
distribution than your depth and test
data learning algorithms are quite
robust student it's super important that
your Deb in test sets come from the same
distribution but if your training set
comes to a slightly different
distribution often that's a pretty
reasonable thing to do and we'll talk
more about how to handle this later this
week so I'd like to wrap up with just a
couple pieces of advice first these
learning researchers sometimes like to
say things like oh I just said the data
the algorithm and I trained in and it
worked and you know there is a lot of
truth to that in the deep learning error
there is more feeding data to an
algorithm than just training it and
doing less hand engineering using less
human insight but I think that in
building practical systems often there's
also more manual analysis and more human
insight that goes into these systems and
sometimes deep learning researchers like
to acknowledge second is that somehow
I've seen some engineers and researchers
be reluctant to manually look at
examples maybe is not the most
interesting thing to do to sit down and
look at 100 or couple hundred examples
to counter the number of errors but this
is something that I still do myself when
I'm reading machine learning to you and
I want to understand what mistakes is
making I will actually go in and look at
the data myself and try to counter the
fraction of errors and I think that
because these you know minutes or maybe
a small number of hours of counting data
can really help you prioritize where to
go next I find this a very good use of
your time that urge you to consider
doing it if you go to machine learning
system and you're trying to decide what
ideas or what directions to prioritize
things
so um that's it for the error analysis
process in the next video I want to
share view some thoughts on how error
analysis fits into how you might go
about starting out on a new machine
learning project